hi my name is Shane glass and I'm the
program manager for Google clouds public
data set program and I'm here today to
talk to you about the public data sets
we have available in bigquery and Google
cloud storage as well as how they can
support your workloads and don't worry
there's a fun demo at the end too now
the mission of our public data set
program is quite simply to maximize the
availability and accessibility of
high-value high demand public data
assets through google cloud and we do
this because we fundamentally believe
that it makes life a little bit easier
for our users we currently have more
than 130 data sets in our public data
set program and these data sets are
on-boarded and maintained it by Googlers
with provider input and guidance you can
see here a sample of our data providers
including NOAA the US Census Bureau
United the United Nations statistics
division the Federal Elections
Commission and others we're constantly
adding new data sets and here are just
three examples of recently added
unstructured data sets all coming from
NOAA the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration they include
a high rep high resolution rapid refresh
weather model the new ghost 16 satellite
imagery and NOAA's national water model
that provides streamflow information
across the continental United States we
also have data sets in bigquery
including the github repository the NOAA
global service summary of the day that
provides meteorological observations
going back to 1900 and the etherium
blockchain along with six other
cryptocurrencies but don't just take my
word for it let's see a demo
specifically looking at how you can use
some of our geospatial datasets to
support your workflows so let's look at
a demonstration that tells you how many
lightning strikes there were across the
continental United States in 2018 thanks
to the lightning data we have available
from NOAA you can see here a query that
runs real quickly and will give you a
concatenation and a little bit cleaner
format so that it's easier to visualize
this data in data studio so we'll click
run down here and a little like they do
in the cooking shows I already have it
finished you can see here the number of
lightning strikes with a center point
of a one-tenth degree by one tenth
degree tile that aggregates the strikes
across the u.s. we'll take a look in
data studio and see what we notice trend
wise will flip over to our cooking show
finished finished version and you can
see here the aggregated number of
lightning strikes across a year on
average but this doesn't really tell us
much as it's hard to see the specific
data points so let's zoom in using the
zoom area function in data studio and
we'll zoom in to the United States and
this is primarily where the data comes
from now I had originally expected
Florida to have the most lightning
strikes per day but as you can see what
really stands out on this map is the
collection of data here in Oklahoma now
I'm curious and I want to dig in further
and how can I use public data sets to do
that now we can use the geospatial
capabilities or GIS that are built into
bigquery and this helps think we
understand the geospatial relationship
between data sets now this particular
query has a little pre-processing time
under the hood but we're hopeful to make
that out that unnecessary here in the
near future for now we'll take the
shortcut and so this query gives us the
return of a polygon for each tile as
well as the number of lightning strikes
by day but let's say we wanted to look
at that in a more visual format what
come over to bigquery geophys the geo
visualization capability available for
free I could come down here and run the
same query see my results and define
which column is our geometry and from
there I give it a style the best fits
our data in this case I've given an
interval for the number of strikes and
the location and I can tell you as a
former Oklahoma resident this makes a
lot of sense to me the areas of Oklahoma
that are notorious for the storms are
also seeing the greatest number of
lightning strikes but this is pretty
broad these are one tenth of a degree by
1/10 that are great tiles across the
state what does that actually mean
no one measures the world intent of
degree tiles instead we define the world
by boundaries in most cases in the US
political and statistical boundaries
such as either counties or census tracts
in this case let's take a look at one of
the ten boundary datasets we have
available in bigquery through the public
dataset program that defines the space
around each of these borders in this
case we'll start with counties that's a
pretty popular one in Oklahoma we're
running pretty similar query except this
time we'll take a little shortcut so
that I only have to remember the state
name as opposed to the state FIPS code
and again we'll run our results and
we'll see the counties this time is the
geometric column and again we can run
our visualization an ad style that meets
the needs of our dataset and one of the
nice features about bigquery geo viz
is it allows me to go in and click on an
individual County and see what the exact
outputs were and we can see here for
example that Oklahoma County has about
three hundred lightning strikes per day
and this pretty closely lines up with
what we saw from the other map except on
a more understandable boundary what if
we want to look at something more
granular though say for instance zip
codes again we'll take the same data set
but this time we'll define it but the
spaces of zip codes or zip code
tabulation areas in this case and we'll
run that through and that gives you a
better idea of maybe what zip code you
want to avoid assuming you don't like
lightning strikes we'll go through the
same process and we'll define the same
style this time let's use a different
method of defining that data-driven
column so let's use a linear
extrapolation we'll give it a low of 27
as you can see the minimum down here and
then we'll go up by 100 from here so one
twenty two twenty three twenty and so on
and I'll want to get over my max of 499
we set the colors down here and I could
scroll through some different options to
find one that suits my palate in this
case I want to do something pretty
similar to the one I use in the counties
and you can see here again there's a
dark concentration here around Oklahoma
City but this time I can drill down to a
more granular level and see which ZIP
codes might make it the most likely for
me to see some lightning strikes in my
backyard
so this is just one example of what can
be done with public datasets if you're
interested in learning more and figuring
out how you can join public datasets
with your private data sets I encourage
you to check out GCP marketplace and
click on datasets on the left hand side
there you can learn more about datasets
and get started in bigquery today